- [Instructor] We're told draw the image
of triangle ABC under a dilation
whose center is P and scale factor is 1/4.
And what we see here is
the widget on Khan Academy
where we can do that.
So we have this figure, this triangle ABC,
A, B, C, right over here,
and what we wanna do is dilate it,
so that means scaling it up or down,
and the center of that
dilation is this point P.
So one way to think
about it is let's think
about the distance between point P
and each of these points,
and we wanna scale it by 1/4.
So the distance is going to be 1/4
of what it was before.
So, for example, this
point right over here,
if we just even look
diagonally from P to A,
we can see that we are
crossing one square,
two squares, three squares, four squares.
So if we have a scale factor of 1/4,
instead of crossing
four squares diagonally,
we would only cross one square diagonally.
So I'll put the corresponding
point to A right over there.
Now, what about for point C?
It's not quite as obvious,
but one way we could think about it
is we can think about how
far are we going horizontally
from P to C, and then how
far do we go vertically?
So horizontally, we're going one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight of these units,
and then vertically we're
going one, two, three, four.
So we're going to the
left eight and up four.
Now, if we have a scale factor of 1/4,
we just multiply each of those by 1/4.
So instead of going to the left eight,
we would go to the left two.
Eight times 1/4 is two.
Instead of going up
four, we would go up one.
So this would be the
corresponding point to point C.
And then we'll do the
same thing for point B.
When we go from P to B,
we're going one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, eight up,
and we're going four to the left.
So if we have a scale factor of 1/4,
instead of going eight
up, we'll go two up,
and instead of going four to the left,
we'll go one to the left.
So there you have it.
We have just dilated triangle ABC
around point P with a scale factor of 1/4,
and we are done.